hi my name is Heather berkey and i am  from the art institute of jacksonville  and I currently reside in Jacksonville  Florida the documentary that I did is  titled lost country and it is about  three Cuban expatriates telling their  stories of how they fought Fidel Castro  and the revolution I hope you enjoy  thank you you don't know how good you  got it until you lose it you don't  receive what you have right now I  believe this is still the greatest  country is this but right now at this  moment I won't think this country a lot  of America see they know how good they  are on a high still has it did they lose  they will lose it the demand by human  beings everywhere even here at home for  dignity to do this by other means than  bullets and blank checks passed around  by blank minds until we do this it will  not be communism that wins the world it  will be democracy with losers  you